si j'étais président de la république
française et si j'avais une
compréhension de ce monde et si donc
j'avais un cerveau je dirais que une
position intéressante pour la france ça
serait d'abord de comprendre sa de
retrouver quelques plus petit reflex
beau lien d'indépendance et de principe
d'égalité entre nations et plus que
plutôt que de courir sans arrêt derrière
l'allemagne de vociférer dans tous les
sens je travaillerai à ce qui serait
pour moi un avenir a cédé 100 pour la
planète d'un rapprochement américano
russes alors je reconnais que je suis un
peu seul dans mon côté pro américain et
pro russe simultanément mais là vous
pouvez penser si vous si vous si vous
passez dans le monde d'après je trouve
que sur le plan géopolitique nacre on
est tout à fait dans un monde d'avant
mais un monde d'avant désorganisé par
les évolutions économiques
si vous projetez dans un monde d'après
dans ce monde après la france puissance
d'équilibré puissance moyenne puissance
incarnant des valeurs universelles
d'égalité pourrait jouer un rôle dans ce
rapprochement n'est on est tellement
loin de ça c'est comme si j'étais en
train de rêver tout la vérité de la
france c'est que bien loin de défendre
des principes d'égalité entre nations
elle a participé avec l'allemagne et en
fidèles suivent en allemagne à
l'écrasement de la grèce si vous voulez
ce qui m'a le plus choqué dans cette
affaire turc c'est d'entendre les gens
dire en france mais on ne va pas laisser
tomber la grèce on va pas laisser tomber
la grèce face à la turquie mais compte
tenu de ce qu'on a fait à la grèce au
moment de la crise financière de ce
qu'on lui a imposée je veux dire je veux
dire c'est c'est à je ne sais pas s'il
faut rire pleurer crier mais c'est
absurde et ça nous donne la garantie que
s'il y avait un véritable conflit entre
la grèce et la turquie
je suis prêt à parier qu'on laisserait
tomber les grecs une fois de plus
[Musique]